only reason why it feels that way is
it's the [ __ ] color
if it was blue like green purple what
did we have in this car you got just
that color it just looks like
a dick you can't nothing
put in my mouth do it
okay my turn
the only thing a little pink little silk
on
and put your lips on the ledge
well this board's looking
tasty it'd be nice to play
go into the orange now yeah
souls are crowded
and especially the scene pays off
with his [ __ ] jason bateman
getting something done
due down to the fame and [ __ ] this is
tom jones todd jones from private books
forever hey can i get the other boss
yeah like buff yeah the other one you
saw by your friend on the floor oh are
you left to be what's up
go ahead nick
the van logo thing sucks hans
he speaks my logo sucks who here thinks
my logo sucks
okay my logo does it let's heart
he didn't think of it first that's why
he's mad
what are you doing it means the water i
forgot myself when i was sitting there
maybe
oh yeah that is yours
yeah i guess if you're like yeah don't
take my [ __ ] water yes
that problem stop
what are you doing you need something
already
the lack of respect
[ __ ] boy hey look at your [ __ ] boy
like a wild board
do you have a tampon in your nose
nose bleeds where's the edibles it's
just like it should be more aged in your
logo
you know where it says
is
santa fonte's turn
and he'll be here in five minutes
surrounding joe
oh
it's aggressive
fish
immediate enemies
like that southern even texas at texas b
draw yeah really
yeah violence oh hi babe no it's a base
it's really good when you have big moon
yeah
nice
they have their own style
i love it a little bit over the ground
even
the juice
that's only a minute 40 seconds
so what do you think about female
comedians in austin are they funny yeah
i love it this is like eric andre show
she's funny ariel
yeah
it's your turn it's my friend oh yeah
you just went twice she was on thanks
yeah
ariel yeah
um ellen
degeneres ellen the genderless yes
yeah arielle isaac norman i'm doing her
show on wednesday
the major talks like 20 minutes after
the show she's pretty cool oh nice
yeah we follow our g's
that's
settling
[Music]
um
oh my god
1 34 okay so this has been a 14 minute
game
i try to keep my turns on in 10 seconds
third time we got 60 seconds inside
just like chess the little time room 60
seconds from rooney
speed guitar
well that's just like a bunch of
[ __ ] going on over there oh
there's just free reign for you
everyone picked up their second
settlement nick oh no i guess i did
second one
green
orange
the vengeance against my people be gays
again
um
wow
nice
you want some of this
chocolate yeah take some chocolate
wow
very welcome
times
oh nine
because that's not the cinnamon one
your childhood too but why don't you eat
that one
um who's up right now
can you pass it on are we good to
everyone
everyone pick up tonight
[Music]
drags
hey
eight
very round
wow
so who's your favorite musician right
now
me personally yeah look at all the time
right now right now
oh i thought you were saying that you
were your favorite musical me
all right
hey what's up gareth your [ __ ] future
uh i love david
sorry dude i'm a little girl
my favorite artists are there's
listening to now
um
i would say one that i like the most
songs
i've never heard of oliver talk about
sex okay bye
come over
okay bye he's uh
he said okay why
six
is
[Music]
all right i need a brick
i have a shirt
so what's the best neighborhood to live
in austin
don't tell anybody
that's funny
this is clear
oh this shit's frozen
see that chocolate 115.
that's like flow dangerous and you have
two
sticks
that's not easy i'll get on this thing
son
i'm gonna do here's a euro plenty
are you nice to use them
well no so i'm not sure i'm going to get
two without you thinking here what i
should get with my other one
sorry no no you're good
you take five would
also
take one rise from the word use the
three rock
to
let's see
nine didn't really see for what they
want to trade
what do you give them i don't know we
are a break
for a super super shoot
do you guys have a way
i need the worst round
this is msg over here
three
six
another six
whoa
you just put there too right really just
operated
we're all coming up literally
rising time
yes all shapes
yeah obviously hope everybody wins
eleven
you rolling one sheesh
it's only you stop
so we're going to
go to settings
how
um
um
wow
my guys eating well over here
oh you guys saw how to sit here that's
funny i wasn't the only one i'm over
here in cuckland
didn't have any brick
for what uh rockstroke
um
do you have word too
no
i'm removing the offer in five four okay
you know i'm jealous
trying to pull a shark tank like i'm
gonna watch that i gotta get the [ __ ]
right off the pile too so if you wanna
see i pulled a shark tank it didn't go
well for me
for one take my 10 seconds coming up
well hold on
it's that orange map you're using you
said for a brick
machine for brick price has changed okay
no kidding all right
and then that's spencer
you're gonna play
[Music]
build the setting
what i rolled
i said he's a settlement stop okay
setting like say dude
what
up
didn't forget this
six
other sheep if anybody has a hay
no no thank you
seven is
killing me
oh my god
okay
i'm not safe
now
he has four points
oh yeah
so i had
yellow to twelve
i didn't know i have a weak heartbreak
sheep
now
in a
you need sheep and wheat yeah
that sound but we have to bring people
who have to move
does anybody have weed at all are we
willing to or
we don't
wear trees
all right
i'm going to trade in four sheep for a
hay and a
sit
five points
and then i'm going to pull i should've
done this already who used my night card
thankful for natalie
that was a fantastic movie sir
we're all really trapped up here
as far as resources are 10
ridge
this guy's about four times don't roll
seven
[Music]
minutes
i want shape
i need to wait who wants rock
rock for a break definitely
so
it's your turn
so this is like a real retro
retro djing now
[Music]
[Music]
of five you're dead
i think it's very good
oh that's off the chart
i'm gonna trade that one get it
in the picture
i traded in four sheet for uh
one
[Music]
one to five
speaking about my yelp okay
what did it stop for my dj
i'm so confused
this is
[Music]
um
yeah but it's been blocked off this
whole time where what's your favorite
yeah here's the date two
what's your favorite note right jersey i
don't know
two or six ten two
for a
sheep who's your what first she
okay
now i was spending some game back then
who's your father let me buy the
business
um
[Music]
we'll put that there
you guys guys five eight
[ __ ]
so i need some residuals
i'm gonna play
the year of plenty projects
themselves right my head copy death card
neurons got like connected think like
this things aren't dropping like a
tongue
you get it
which two did you take oh okay
sorry it took me a second no you're good
here four four let's go finally
something
i
know you take a rock that was true
yeah right appreciate your dog mom
yeah yeah man yeah
[Music]
that
we got this [ __ ] actually
what are you talking about
hey i'm walking
a brick for a sheep
i think so
fix
everybody
dmg56 you guys look like squirrels now
we are squirrels
we very nice
dude i boosted my wasn't my baby
yeah that's like that's top shelf
correct seriously
well there's something thanks so much
uh success delivery let's make some i'm
just gonna run out of water
oh [ __ ] me
like
this
i forgot you're wondering
oh perfect
i'm gonna build this city
so
three for one for a hay three fourth for
a head for this guys
man
great
thank you
you say foreign
uh
food stations back in detroit oh really
887 used to be
there is like this thing at like 97.9
will be going once rock
for what
7 a.m yeah it's like this like cool like
jazz wave funk house type [ __ ]
and it was always just kind of like you
know music you know you would never hear
again right
i know exactly what you're talking about
always work at 7am because it's like an
hour drive to work exactly yeah
so
i can't help it there's a lot of songs i
had just recorded because i didn't have
shazam yet at that time yeah so stirs
recorded
once it's down though you know
you're right you know what this down
is down
sponge is a band you don't usually think
of let me be like what should i put on
oh man my mind is just expanded and i
can found out anything
[Music]
this one though
from
guess what movie this is from
that's when
my favorite movie of all time now
i was trying to rent to that store but i
wasn't like 17 to rent and i beg people
i think i need the warriors like to rent
it holy [ __ ] i love the baseball guys
dude they were look at the sparks yeah i
love that the baseball gang that was my
[ __ ] yeah that's so pretty
honestly movies are so good from like
the ladies
these guys up don't worry
that cool and they start lighting [ __ ]
on fire because you know a song
favorite science and language nostalgia
community too dude like i haven't seen
her trains you've heard of it yeah
superhero like buffalo bill whether
she's not well i mean
and i never thought i was like a woman i
always thought it was like a me and see
him and i should have moved that at the
beginning of my turn
damn
dude
anybody have sheep
no silence of the lambs uh
their buffalo bills dancing in the
mirror with the tuft and stuff
i don't ever see that movie before yeah
well then you know i should watch it
together i'm gonna go ahead and
the light
objects on the scrolls even more
oppression
[Music]
um
six thanks
you want to have a rock
huh you want that way back for a rock
you need a rock yeah
for a week
i should have traded with you
234
was a fair trade you offered it to me i
knew you were going to do that
you're winning too hard already
joe been reaching the end of my line
two four five six
five
yeah required who wouldn't take from
david
oh he isn't
the game has gone out of hand and he's
nicer
is
[Music]
[Music]
is coming
nick rush oh sorry nick rose on his way
yeah really yeah intro
two
oh smooth this is happy marketing
maybe that'll be my turn
three leaves one of these three these
pilot would get like food poisoning or
something
healthy
i don't know i just wish you
if something bad happened i wouldn't be
upset i love that
why you to stay yeah
so they will just have like 911 part two
happened right now oh by the way nick
got along this road i don't know
who incredible
is
you're the longest word oh no no no no
a little bit stick to my hand to do
about it
not none of this day and then well i
mean do you believe like would you want
to go there [ __ ] hours this day yes
this age hoping someone
don't have poop is
they want some i'm okay i got him
you know what i mean just trying to
think of something clever
i'm trying
some wheat action the most important
part is trying
well
i'm gonna have to
like screw it
down where'd it go
well if i like
[Music]
yeah that's not funny all he's rolling
seven past two games yeah that songs
that's so impressive it's awesome he's
an automatic night well you're coming
i'm here for me why are you nothing from
him i'm not taking him for everyone now
i don't have one vote for david he's
winning
we're all pretty close
oh no orange is still in this game
he's got road right now
who's staying after this who wants to
play another one
are you playing another one did anybody
have any trees
i don't know what are you doing
no dude i'm kidding i was going to be
with the chicken
there's a third player coming another
one internet
no just nick oh but we need we've got
rocks right here
well let me know now because he's coming
he's on his way now
from the last game do you want to leave
then tell him not to come
seven i mean you can still hang out with
him yeah and then have over here with
people that's just the opposite
yeah that's true
i need a structure i'm just analyzing
this
well no i'm coming from a depressing
i'm not driving like
i can do it at a while
i can pick a little bit too i guess
sheep
from the exchange
you're going to sheep i got you
so
awesome
foreign
um
we need to help the pogba with this road
11.
let's go why are you helping him with
time so that you don't get
8.9 points eight points
is that true
yeah
four seconds
that's a sixth awesome
it's what papa needed yeah
does anybody have trees
for what brick i could get out
let me do that
what
yeah
that's seven points
jesus
said
i think you can so much
eleven
let me get
yeah two four six oh yeah
they're all the same
really yeah
so i'm gonna finish two bricks first
should be
another development card
and
that's going to be my
turn
now to just the largest army
okay
now i'm going three rows
five
it wants bricks
it's big right now
eleven
oh shoot
i got sheep if anybody's got wheat
right now
or five
okay next oh yeah
great
two roads we'll take along this road
in
this game
and
yeah i think do i need that
no you don't need that okay so did he
just do he scored 11 points on us yeah
so that means he goes back to sir
again
everyone won
the 8th grade
yeah the knights
the sevens
have been built long ago
because i was just racking in these over
here
for myself getting rocks over
the most important thing
what's the most important thing yeah
winning where are your time how do you
win
what's the best way to win just by
winning it doesn't matter how or why one
two last night just don't be a loser
come on right
how many we play too it's a room full of
winners
where's the uh phallic ball back one
more before i roll
[ __ ] bone
bomb
is there cinnamon cinnamon now
[ __ ] up the first one
which one they [ __ ] up i think i
honestly like more
yeah the soccer one they put upside down
right yeah
it was a
prophecy
hoses
what along is but just a gateway for
drugs
what else do we use them for they're
like pretty much useless besides that
breathing
what about
fish i do that
weed
and carbon monoxide
doesn't it grow still coming over again
yeah
here we go
take my lighter back
there
is my line being lighter probably
anywhere or is it
[Music]
see you man thank you for having me
yesterday praying
yeah good to see you bro you see ryan
though
what come for your phone
underground
again
[Music]
oh
okay
i believe he was here all high
is
yeah i'm looking forward to it already
finally
you won once
oh yeah
to be fair everyone else was in another
universe
i was doing good i had six points
on this point i expected to win at least
two games
you're working away with zero everyone
else won once
yeah nick won
all right i think we're done thank you
guys
love you
sorry i feel so abrupt last time it's a
nice send off goodbye